good evening everyone
thank
are coming today
so we're very fortunate to have
Professor Kevon Mancha from the
University of Cambridge speaking to us
but prior to introducing him I just
wanted to say a few words about the
person for whom this lecture is named so
this is a this is miss endo been pot and
she was married to dr. Provine pot who
we're fortunate have with us today and
dr. Provine pot has has had a very long
association with Yale so he was a Yale
research scholar now retired and
secretary emeritus of the South Asian
Studies Council which is sponsoring this
talk and he started the South Asian
Studies program here in 1991 and he
dedicated this lecture series in loving
memory of his wife whose picture you see
up here and to commemorate their joint
work on South Asia and in Dubin was
revered by many students who were
welcomed in her home for family meals
conversations and discussions to
compensate for her being away from home
and providing services to students and
scholars around the world and let me now
turn to our speaker for today so
professor Kevin mucci
is he currently holds a Frank Ramsey
chair so do I need to
this yes so professor Chiron country
currently holds the Frank Ramsey chair
in economics at the University of
Cambridge which is a very prestigious
post previously held by Starr bartha's
Gupta for many many years and so we're
very fortunate to have Kevin here today
before we have to start calling him Sir
which probably will happen a few years
and he's one of the world's foremost
experts on how community networks shape
economic activity so it's his early work
studied migrant networks from Mexico to
the United States and more recently he
studied how caste networks in India
allow members to share risk right in in
situations where they're facing lots of
risk but do not have access to formal
insurance networks and he's also studied
how network defect mobility both in the
context of historical United States
African American networks in the United
States moving from the south to the
north as well as Kastner networks in
India and in these cases what's
interesting is that the networks can
either pay a positive or a negative role
either enhancing or preventing mobility
from one place to another so his body of
work on the effects of networks on
education health mobility are all of
first order importance for understanding
growth and development and he's
published widely but more importantly
the work is really important it's
influenced at my own work and the work
of many young scholars because networks
are an important element of how society
is organized and most recently Chi Minh
won the Infosys prize in the social
sciences that was in 2016 and that's
immense this place is one of the leading
social scientists working on issues of
relevance to South Asia and this is why
we thought about inviting him that he's
one of the foremost scholars on on South
Asia and we're very lucky to have him
speak to the South Asian Studies Council
thank you Kevin for coming thank you
very much for inviting me it's a great
honor and I'm very pleased to be here
so this is
actually the the first paper in a much
larger project that I've been engaged in
for many years now examining the role
that communities play in different ways
in shaping health outcomes in rural
South India in particular in Vellore
district you can see from the long list
of co-authors this is also an
interdisciplinary list that many people
have been involved at different stages
in this project there's going to be
research on communicable diseases
tuberculosis in particular we have work
on non communicable diseases
we have work on nutrition and this is
work on sex selections so this in some
sense is a preview of more work that is
going to come in the coming years so let
me just jump ahead and begin with the
presentation so sex selection through
female feticide infanticide or neglect
is a serious problem in India a martyr's
sin sort of brought this problem to
public attention more than 25 years ago
when he famously claimed that more than
100 million women were missing in Asia
and since that time India has made
enormous economic progress as you know
and we might expect that what this
economic progress would come greater
gender equality but at least on this
particular dimension if anything the
problem has worsened so here is just a
slide which gives you a sense of the
magnitude of the problem so typically
when the government of India or in fact
you know many governments release
statistics on child sex ratios it's for
children aged 0 to 6 and so that's what
I'm doing over here and the way that we
actually report this as the number of
boys per hundred guns okay and so the
first question to ask befall of course
is what is the natural benchmark what
would you have without any kind of sex
selection so at birth you will have
about a hundred and five boys 200 girls
but that gap narrows very quickly now
you don't have a standard sort of bench
for the 0 to 6h group but what you can
use is a sex ratios that were in place
in South India prior to the 1980s so
just generally believe that till the
early 1980s there was no sex selection
in South India now I'll tell you more
about this in a moment so if you take
for example South Indian statistics from
the 1971 census or from the 1961 census
that would give us a sort of benchmark
and for the 0 to 6 H category it works
out to about 100 and 2.5 boys to 100
girls ok so let's take that as the
benchmark you take that as the benchmark
you can see right away that the worst
states in the country are really very
far from the natural level in Haryana
for example you now have a hundred and
twenty boys to 100 girls aged 0 to 6
Punjab and Delhi are not far behind now
if you look at the national level the
national average it looks relatively you
know less severe it's it's now about 109
but notice that South India which as I
said had almost no sex selection prior
to 1980 now is almost caught up with the
national average okay so these are just
some statistics and the question to ask
of course is where exactly is the
problem where should we focus if we
wanted to address this particular
problem now of course if you look I mean
it's natural to focus on these
particular North Indian states because
it's so sensational and it doesn't
certainly help that the capital of the
country is right there at the very top
and as you might imagine if you if you
if you if you look at the you know the
media coverage you look at the public
the public discourse a lot of the
attention is devoted to these particular
problematic states all of which are in
North India but the point that I want to
make today in the paper is that we
should also focus on on the All India
level because there is in fact within
particular sub subpopulations
substantial variation in sex ratios and
what we're going to be talking about
today is variation within caste or jaw
T's so for those of you are not familiar
with the Indian social structure Indian
society is divided up into endogamy
scars or jaw T's there are about 4,000
cars in the country and the and the
basic rule is that you must married
within your caste I've been working for
now as mochiko saying maybe 10 or 15
years on the role played by caste
networks in shaping different types of
economic activity the reason why these
networks are organized around the caste
is because individuals marry within the
class that is very strong social ties
which can be exploited to support and
sustain different kinds of economic
activities when I began this research
there was actually very little
information about the level of marriage
within these cars when I was doing these
surveys in different parts of the
country I kept getting this number where
95 percent of people reported marrying
within their cost since that time there
been a couple of large-scale national
representative surveys like the Reds
like the ihds and they also come up with
the same number and more importantly
there is no recent genetic evidence
which tells us that Indians have been
marrying in this way for 2,000 to 4,000
years and so the point that I want to
make is that if you look within this
costs within this caste which is what
people are doing this paper you're going
to find enormous variation in sex ratios
in fact a variation within castes in a
single district in South India which is
actually quite unexceptional it's going
to be as large as a variation across all
states in the country and that to my
mind is the punchline of this research
this is something which has never been
seen before and the reason why we can
show you this is because of the unique
data that we have collected as part of
this project now
the next sort of thing is once you've
documented this variation the next
question to ask of course is why do you
see this variation in sex ratios within
costs and so for this we're going to
turn to the marriage institution in
India because as I said one thing which
is very particular to these cars is that
people marry within them there's a
there's essentially a marriage a unique
a distinct exclusive marriage market
within each caste and we're going to do
is to examine in great detail the way
that this marriage market actually
functions as a way of understanding the
root cause of the sex selection and how
the sex selection varies within the cost
so we're not the first people to link
the marriage institution to sex
selection and Indian right this is very
widely believed that the main cause of
sex selection in India isn't
the is in fact the marriage institution
and particularly the dowry so here is
fighting for example and in an
advertisement from an ultrasound clinic
which says is your baby boy or girl an
ultrasound examination will tell you now
this of course was in the old days
before the this kind of sex selection
was made illegal but there was in fact
an even more famous or infamous
advertisement which is the title of this
slide which was literally outside an
ultrasound clinic which said pay five
thousand now save five lakh later and so
that's the sense in which in India there
is this notion that basically if you
have a girl you'd add a disadvantage
because you have to pay all of this
money at the time of marriage it is also
widely believed that the wealthy are
more likely to practice sex selection
because they have to pay higher dowries
now you must understand that there is a
limitation to this kind of argument
because of course it is true that the
wealthy pay higher dalories but their
daughters also marry into wealthier
households where they will end up
consuming at higher level so if the
girl's parents internalize the benefit
that these girls derive from marrying up
in this way of marrying a wealthy
household in this way then in fact they
may not be worse off having a girl
believed to a less wealthy household so
one of the contributions that we are
going to that we that we would like to
make here is to think more closely or
more clearly about the link between
wealth marriage and sex selection as a
way of understanding this variation in
sex ratios within castes which we are
going to uncover okay so in some sense
this is the sort of two-pronged
objective here
the first is descriptive it's empirical
to look within the cost using the new
data that we have and the second is more
theoretical to try to think about what
it is about imagine situation in India
which that that gives rise to sex
collection in the first place and how
the sex collection varies within the
caste across the wealth distribution and
to make this connection it's actually
useful to think a little bit about the
South Indian experience so as I said
prior to the 1980s there was no sex
selection in South India the the the of
course you always had you know marriage
within within the cost this was true in
North India it was also true in South
India but
the additional feature of marriage in
South India was that was that basically
people married very close relatives so
the most preferred match for a girl was
either her mother's younger brother or
if he was unavailable one of the mothers
brothers sons now marriage in India and
this is going to be very important as we
go forward is paid to local what this
means is that when the girl marries she
leaves her natal home and moves into her
husband's home so in this case with this
particular pattern of marriage two close
relatives the girl was essentially
moving into either her maternal
grandfather's home or her maternal
uncle's home so this of course is a very
close relationship these are people that
she knows very very well the families
are very closely tied to each other
so one way to think about this is that
this was almost like a cooperative
arrangement it was a reciprocal
arrangement between two dynasties over
many generations but they would
basically send girls back and forth in
one generation the girl would go from
one side to the other the next
generation her daughter would go back in
the opposite direction and this would
just keep on going from one generation
to the next
there was no payment at the time of
marriage except for a small ritual
payment which was known as a three-ton
there was nothing else the girls you the
family was not disadvantaged if it had a
daughter and as a result there was no
sex selection okay so that is the
pattern that anthropologists have
painted for us prior to the early
nineteen nine 1980s now this appears to
have changed with economic development
so social scientists like Sreenivas like
Caldwell who who really understand I
think you know South Indian society very
well they linked this change to economic
development and the basic idea that they
put forward is that once you have
economic development families or
dynasties that were very well matched on
wealth over many many generations
suddenly were not so there's a social
anthropologist Karan Kapadia who has a
wonderful ethnography of a Tamil village
just around the time when all this
change was actually occurring and she
describes how women for example who had
married in a particular you know in the
traditional way and then suddenly found
that their husbands are doing extremely
well did not want their daughters to
marry their younger brothers who were in
a totally different world economically
now
and so in some sense what really brought
about the change was this push from the
girls side to actually stop this kind of
marriage and perhaps also from the boys
side and to find a partner who was more
sort of economically suitable and so all
of a sudden what ended up happening you
were still married within the caste that
didn't change but now you did not marry
in the traditional fashion to a
particular close relative never happen
is you in some sense married on the
market and what you had were dalories
coming in to essentially clear the
marriage market the dowry in some sense
was a price to clear the marriage market
and people have noticed this in fact
there is an economist at the World Bank
rajendra Rao who has done some very
interesting work on dowry in the 1990s
and what he finds is that in factories
in South India and now as high as they
are in something they're sorry in not
India so things have jury started to
change now around the same time in the
night study from the 1980s you also
started to see sex selection kicking in
in South India and it's tempting from
the intertemporal correlation to link
the dowry to the sex selection but the
point that we want to make is that what
really drove the sex selection was not
the dowry per scene it was specific
features of the marriage market which
also emerged at just about the same time
and that is what's going to give rise at
least in our theory to the sex selection
okay so this is sort of the background
and when we try to actually understand
better the link between marriage and sex
selection we will draw on particular
features of the marriage institution in
India and this is sort of you know these
these are the sort of key features that
we would take out that we will use in
our analysis both for the theory as well
as for the epics the first one which I
mentioned earlier is that marriages in
India and dogmas within the cost or the
jothee the second feature is that
marriages are arranged with wealth being
the major consideration and again with
general Rajas some work where he looks
at the determinants of the matching
between families or between partners and
of course individual characteristics do
matter like education or the looks of
the partners but the the prime driving
force is the wealth of the families
that's what they are matching and in our
in our model we're going to focus
exclusively on this wealth matching
between households the
word feature of Merit which is relevant
for us is of course this notion of a
dowry the fact that at the time of
marriage there is a payment from the
girls side to the boys side the fourth
feature of marriage is that it a special
local that the girl moves into her
husband's home at the time of marriage
and the fifth feature is the social norm
that all girls must marry there is a
huge social stigma in India if a girl
remains single and these last two
features of marriage institution are
going to be the proximate determinants
of sex selection in our model as you
will see all of these other features
would play a role but it's the last two
which are going to basically drive the
sex selection okay now before I get to
the model and that's what I'm going to
ask you I'm gonna probably tax you all a
little bit when I get to that to that
section let me just give you a little
background on the study and some sort of
descriptive sort of statistics which
show you that the marriage institution
in our study area looks pretty much like
what I just listed for you so as I said
what what this is sort of part of a
larger project which we call the South
India Community Health Study it covers a
rural population in the state of in in
the state of Tamil Nadu in the in
Vellore district and this is for those
of you who are not familiar with the
geography of India Tamil Nadu is
basically the southernmost state in
India and the Lord District is actually
the northern is literally the northern
edge of Tanana it's right up against on
repetition it's a it's sort of you know
halfway between Bangalore and Chennai
okay
and our study area basically covers
about half of rural velour district it's
not contiguous but because the the
reason for this is because it's also
part of a larger project on tuberculosis
and so there were you know reasons why
we picked this particular area but it
turns out to be actually quite
fortuitous as you will see because the
study area is very representative of
both rural Tamil Nadu as well as rural
South India which we define by the
states of Maharashtra Tamil Nadu
Karnataka and Andhra Pradesh in terms of
socio-economic characteristics and
demographic characteristics so if you
look at the age distribution if you look
at marriage patterns
look at literacy if you look at labor
force participation you will see that
our study ruler Tamilnadu row South
India line up almost perfectly okay and
so what I'm gonna argue is that the area
that we are working in is very is not
special at all it's just a generic place
there's nothing special at all about it
now in the analysis today because I make
use of two components of the six the
first is a census of all the 300,000
households in the study area that we
conducted as I said this is the
population of 1.1 million so this is a
large enterprise
we basically collected you know not
detailed information but certainly you
know info you know important basic
information about every individual in
each of these households we followed
this up with the detailed survey of
5,000 households that we collected lots
of information about transfers between
households investments that parents
making the children including the time
they spend on them lots of information
about health and education as well as on
marriage and so we're going to use both
of these these data sources in the
analysis today so here is data from the
household survey and I just want to show
you that you know some of the key
features the marriage institution show
up very clearly in our study area so as
I told you earlier 95 percent of Indians
appear to marry within that cost and
that's exactly what you see over here so
basically the little sliver that you see
this little gray sliver that you see
that's the fraction of individuals both
in the parental generation as well as in
the children among the children who
married outside of their caste and it's
basically less than 5 percent among
those who marry within the caste in the
parental generation about 50 percent
married a close relative this is now
declined to about 35 percent and if you
look at whether the marriages are
arranged or not somewhere between 80 and
90 percent of the marriages are arranged
so that hasn't changed at all over the
generations what about the dowry and as
I said now dowries in South India are
just as high as they are in North India
in our data what you find is that the
dowry is somewhere between 3 to 4 times
the households annual income so to put
this in perspective if you wanted to buy
a house in the US or in the UK you could
get about two and a half times your
annual income from the bank these
households in rural India who have
access to no formal credit at all or any
kind of formal in you know financial
institution are able to somehow come up
with three to four times that annual
income and in past work that I've done
with Mark Rose's fight what we find is
that the source of the funds are
basically the same this is the caste
networks themselves which support these
people at the time of marriage but
regardless of what it is what's clear is
that this is a huge amount of money the
other thing which is interesting is if
you can see here the amount that the
that the boys say they received is less
than the amount that the girls say they
gave and this is not an artifact of the
data this is actually exactly what was
predicted by a model and the reason for
that is because of been there is sex
selection there's a shortage of girls
and so very naturally you get what is
known as hypergamy where girls end up on
average marrying with wealthier boys and
as a result of that they end up paying a
higher dowry than boys at the same
greville are going to receive and you
can see the hypergamy in our data as
well so we have one question when we ask
the parent about the spa about the
child's spouses family so the question
was is when the child married was the
spouses family of the same wealth higher
wealth or lower wealth and what you find
is that for the boys nine percent say
that they married into a wealthier
family verse four the girls it is 18
percent and for the boys twenty nine
percent say they made into a less
wealthy family whereas for the girls it
is 17 percent now this is just a
response to one question but we're now
working we have new data now on the
marital villages of all of the marriage
partners and so we're gonna be using
that to look more carefully at this kind
of hypergamy and to look at how this
varies across the wealth distribution
but that's not going to be ready for a
little while but still in the process we
have some preliminary results which are
very promising but for now this is what
we have now with this background what I
want to do is to now take you into a
slightly unfamiliar territory for those
of you who are not economists I want to
actually
take you through in a very verbal way
and economic model okay and this is not
the easiest thing I realize and this is
not going to be the most exciting part
of the talk this is not a very exciting
talk anyway because I actually want you
all to think more about the fundamentals
and less about all the you know
sensational stuff but I think for us to
understand why it is the case that you
have sex selection and what is a link
between the marriage institution and sex
selection we really have to think more
seriously about the fundamentals about
the economics so why don't you bear with
me it's going to take a little while and
for those and and you might have to you
know for those of you that not
economists use your imaginations a
little bit because actually thinking in
this way is not easy I realize the key
feature of an economic model is that
it's not going to try to explain every
feature of the world that we live in a
good economic model is essentially a
caricature of the world it tries to pick
out those features of the world that are
most relevant for the polymer that we're
trying to study so in this particular
model it's going to be very stripped
down as you will see what we will try to
do is to capture those aspects of the
marriage institution that do not to be
relevant for sex selection okay so to
begin with each family is going to be
very strange over here it's going to
consist of a single parent so we don't
give a gender to the parent it could be
a man or a woman or whatever it is and a
single child now what matters of course
is the gender of the child so a child is
going to be either a boy or a girl okay
we're going to assume that parents are
altruistic these are all very extreme
assumptions we're doing it in a way to
sort of set it up so that we're going to
shut down many other soil X explanations
for what we're going to find so parents
are completely altruistic they care as
much about their children's consumption
as for their own consumption and in
addition they don't care about the
child's gender so there's no intrinsic
preference for boys in this model the
prevalence of boys is going to come out
naturally or endogenous ly from the
structure of the marriage institution
okay and the other feature sorry
there's gonna be one parent per child so
we're not thinking about a father and a
mother here is just going to be a parent
I want you to as I said use your
imagination this is the sort of fairy
tale but it's a way of sort of stripping
down and trying to you know and there's
just one child there's not multiple
children again it's just one child
okay now marriage is going to be paired
to local what to its means is as I said
that the girl leaves her parental home
at the time of marriage and moves into
her husband's home and so the one way to
think about the dowry is that it's
actually a price in the marriage market
the other way to think about the dowry
is that it's actually a pre-mortem
bequest and that's how people have
actually thought about it in the past so
in India for example when when when the
father dies his son is going to inherit
the property etc things have changed now
I understand the property laws have
changed but it is traditionally when the
father died the sons would inherit the
property so how would he then give a
bequest to his daughter the way he gave
a bequest to his daughter want me to
think about this was through the dowry
so darling was in some sense her
inheritance but the important feature of
the dowry it was is that it did not go
directly to her it went to her her
husband's parent in our model and then
through him as you will see some of it
ultimately came down to her but it did
come go directly to her and as a result
there's going to be a lot of seepage
along the way it's going to get some of
things gonna get siphoned off by her
in-laws and that is going to be one
distortion that's going to give rise to
sex selection in our model as you will
see okay so here is a way of thinking
about the structure of this of this
particular set of hero marriage
institution so I've actually drawn two
parents over here but I kind of put them
on top of each other do you think of it
as one person okay just to make it I
didn't give them a gender so I kind of
made a man and a woman somehow you know
so that's the parent there's a girl's
parent in yellow and then there's the
boy's parent in blue okay and I've set
it up so that to begin with
they both the both parents have whelk of
100 units each the girl's parent has to
decide how much dowry to give and I'm
just making up these numbers okay so
there's nothing you know there's nothing
under underlying this I just made them
up
so I'm going to say that
this girl's friend is going to give a
dowry of 45 to the boy's parent so now
the boys parent has a total wealth of
145 right and what does he do he gives
80 as a transfer to his son and he keeps
therefore 11 five for himself for his
own consumption now this 80 is going to
be divided up between the boy and his
wife so this is the second sort of
seepage that creeps in and the basic
idea here is because the the wife lives
with her husband there's no way that she
can be excluded entirely the father
would like to give or the parent would
like to give everything to the son but
because the girl and the son lived
together she's gonna get some share of
it and the boy is gonna get some share
of it and we're gonna assume that she's
gonna get less than half so in this case
she gets 35 and the boy gets 45 and now
you can start to see how this particular
structure which is basically built
around the structure of the mazzard
situation in India gives rise to
different types of distortions if the
girl's parent could give the mind
directly to the daughter we've assumed
here that this person is altruistic that
person would just share the wealth
equally keep 50 for herself and give 50
to the daughter but because she knows
that she's got to give this dowry which
is gonna get eaten up by the boy's
parent and by the boy as well along the
way ends up giving less than 50 so now
the girls pend is consuming 55 and has
given 45 in dowry but even the 45
doesn't get to the girl only 35 comes to
the girl and from the boy's parents
perspective there's also a seepage
because what the boy spent would like to
do is to be to give half of the
consumption to the boy and keep half for
himself but he can't do that when he
gives the transfer the girl ends up
taking 35 leaving only 45 for the boy so
you can see here that there is
particular sort of seepages in the model
and this is what's going to give rise to
the sex selection so now that we have
this set up what I'm going to do is to
take you through three steps at this
point what I had was two households
coming together with wealth of 100 each
the first step is to actually model the
matching how the households in this
marriage market on the boys
and the girls I match with each other
the next step is talk about the sex
selection and to show that there is sex
selection at every wealth level and the
last step is to have to show how the sex
selection worries across the world
distribution that brings us back to
where we started which is what to try to
explain how the sex ratio is vary within
these castes
okay so let's start off for the first
thing which is the matching so my claim
is that in this particular set up you're
gonna have what is called positive or
sort of matching their wealthy girls
where wealthy parents of girls match
with wealthy parents of boys and now of
course the Dow is going to play two
functions it's going to be a big quest
as we discussed earlier it's also going
to be a price to clear the marriage
market and so the first question to ask
is why does it end up this way why did
the why do the wealthy girl's parents
end up paying a high dowry to get them
married to wealthy boys and the reason
of course is because of the bequest
motive they want their girls to consume
at a higher level because they
themselves starting about a higher level
of wealth so they're willing to pay a
higher dowry so that the girls will
marry with a wealthy family and the
wealthy parent and on the other side is
going to give a larger transfer but some
of which is gonna come down to the girl
herself now ultimately all those parents
want to match with the wealthiest boys
and so the dowry has to be increasing
steeply enough to separate out these
different families on the girls side so
that at the end of the day is the
wealthiest parents of the girls who
match with the wealthiest parents of the
boys and so forth as you move down the
birth distribution so what this shows
you is how you're going to end up with
positive dowries because of the bequest
and also steeply increasing dowries not
because the boys are demanding more
money is because the worldly girl's
parents are trying to separate
themselves from the less wealthy girl's
parents okay now once you have this
matching structure the next step as I
said is to show that there is in fact
sex selection at every wealth level now
this requires a little bit of
concentration so let me try to give you
the the intuition and let him let me see
where I can get this across to you all
but those of you don't have an economics
background okay
but they can't there's a marriage market
right so basically they can't there's
there's a mock you'll see this as we go
to the model that's the don't think
about the dowry as a as a market
clearing price so at the end this this
price is gonna be determining
equilibrium just like you would with any
price at any market so it's not that
they're so they would like to get as
much as they can and you will see that
but it's but they cannot demand you know
any amount that they want because at the
end of the day that always be some other
boy who might be less wealthy who would
to go with a slightly lower dollar so
the Dow is going to basically adjust in
equilibrium so that the market
essentially clears itself okay so yeah
so I'll be taking questions throughout
the thing or it's totally up to you I'm
happy to go either way
yeah could we do that because I and
there might be easier if that's okay
that would solve the whole problem as
you can see and I'll talk about that
later on yeah exactly so what what we're
trying to do is just sort of look at the
structure of this margin situation and
say what is it precisely about this
match institution that's giving us this
in this problem and you can see you as a
mystical lack of commitment that they
cannot give it directly and the voice
pain of course is you know once he gets
the money he's gonna do exactly what he
wants to do and that's the problem right
yeah you have another question
but that's precisely the one gonna think
about the bequests is that she's
basically getting this inheritance and
but and the reason why you need the
dowry is because the boys pen is not
going to accept so in our model there
will always be positive daughters and I
come to this in a second and the reason
because without then why would he ever
you know and you just gonna come out
right right this moment because of some
sense
he's your right he's basically she's
gonna live off them for the for the rest
of her you know time right and she so
what she's bringing in in some sense is
the dowry as a sort of fear oh yeah yeah
absolutely so this is why I said we have
to win one you want this to be sort of
an abstracting so we've been abstracting
away from all these other things there's
no education this model there's no
children in the model so all of that is
sort of you know there's no production
in this model so in some sense you need
to sort of you know think about it as it
is which is just a way of just getting a
sense of you know the intuition of what
is going on over here those are all
important considerations don't get me
wrong that's what I'm saying and this is
the thing right so and you would think
that this is important grandchildren you
know one reason why the boys spend might
might want to actually give something to
her it's because of the grandchildren
but which were shutting down all of
these things here it's just a single
generation there's a fixed amount of
wealth and so this is where now we can
talk about the sex selection so what is
special about this model is that there's
no production here you have a wealth
endowment and so you think now about you
know basically a boy's family with
wealth X and a girl's family with wealth
Y and they've come together the marriage
market let us say okay we're not to
think it could be anything X&Y it could
be any number we don't really care about
it so what's the total wealth that they
have it's X plus y and the question is
in this model is how is this X plus y
going to be distributed between the boys
side and the girls side and what turns
out to matter a lot for this is the
outside option what they would get
outside of marriage and so the
assumption that we're going to make is
that from the boys side the outside
option the lower
bound on staying in the marriage is
basically what the boy and his parent
would get if they just was if he was
single in which case they would have X
and then being altruistic the boys pen
would give X over to half of that to the
son and keep the other half for himself
now what about the girls side now
remember here there is a social norm
that all girls must marry so from the
girls side there is no such lower bound
and that is going to turn out to
basically create an imbalance within the
marriage the boys have an outside option
but the girls don't have an outside
option but they're going to end up as
you will see in a moment getting less
than their share of this total pipe and
to understand that let's go a little bit
now into some very basic economics so
the basic assumption in economics when
it comes to consumer behavior is that
the more you consume the greater utility
you get right individuals are insatiable
that's one assumption but the second
assumption is that for every extra unit
that you consume the extra utility that
you get keeps going down and that is
what is called diminishing marginal
utility so now you think about a boy's
parent with wealth X and he is fully
altruistic he wants to maximize the
utility of his of his own consumption
and his son's consumption so what is he
going to do he was split it equally
between the two of them so that the
marginal utility for both the boy and
the father is exactly the same and the
point here is that in this particular
setup of ours the most efficient way to
use a fixed amount of resources between
a parent and the child is to divide it
up equally if you want to get to that
same level of utility and you don't
divide up the resources equally you will
need more resources than that so now
when the boy and the father go into the
marriage they are going to end up
consuming in a different level why is
that and that goes back to my simple
example if you remember the reason is
because the boy's father even though is
fully altruistic he's going to end up
consuming more than his son and the
reasons because he knows that whatever
transfer he gives some of that is going
to get such siphoned off by the gun and
as a result he will end up consuming
more than his son now because the two of
them are consuming a different level in
when in the marriage institution they
will need more than X
to get to the same level of utility that
they would get which is their outside
option if the boy was single but given
that the total pie is X plus y if they
end up consuming more than X then the
girls side can end up consuming less
than Y so now you can think about this
if you're a girl's parent and you have
you and you have wealth Y if your if
your girl gets married and she has to
get married if she because once she's a
girl you and the girl together will get
less than Y for your own consumption but
if you were able to select and switch
from a girl to a boy you would get more
than Y for the same reason that I just
told you so you are basically better off
having a boy than having a girl now of
course there's going to be a cost to sex
selection not everybody is going to just
therefore switch over and have a boy as
a result but you can imagine there's
going to be a distribution of costs and
as long as that distribution of costs is
such that there are some families with a
very very very low cost of sex selection
then you will always have some amount of
sex selection at every wealth level so
that is the second result so the first
result that I showed you was that you
have positive sort of matching on wealth
the second result now is that you have
sex selection at every wealth level the
last step in this whole process is to
look at how sex selection varies across
the wealth distribution so what I've
done now is to give you a very simple
example again but I fixed the sex ratio
so we know that there is sex selection
but our set is now that every wealth
level you could have two boys to one gun
okay and you're positive sort of
matching which means that the wealthiest
boys match with the wealthiest girls and
we keep going down the distribution
right so one of the wealthiest boys is
going to match with the wealthiest girl
the second boy of course can't do that
he's going to go down one level normally
go down to the second level one of the
boys is going to match down one level
the other boy is going to match two
levels down when you go to the third
level one boy matches two levels down
the other boy marries matches three
levels down so what you're seeing here
is that as you move down the wealth
distribution the wealth gap is
mechanically getting bigger and bigger
so you know that this cannot be in
equilibrium because as you move down
girls are girls parents are less
Vantage for having a girl because
they're matching up with wealthier and
wealthier boys and as a result this sex
ratio must adjust so that as you move
down the wealth distribution in fact it
was thought to become slightly more
favorable towards the guns and so the
basic prediction here is that as you
move down the wealth distribution you
will see less sex selection now this of
course is a very simple model but have
completely ignored the dowry the fact
that the sex selection and you know it
sort of endogenously determined with the
wealth distribution etc so the actual
model in the paper is quite complicated
but this gives you the basic intuition
to solve it out analytically is very
difficult but we can show however is
there are two points in the wealth
distribution at the very top of the
wealth distribution where the wealthiest
girls and the wealthiest boys with equal
wealth match with each other you can
show that sex selection is increasing
with wealth at the lowest level at which
boys marry that's the best level at
which these boys basically end up
getting just an outside option nothing
more than that
we can also show over there that sex
selection is increasing with wealth but
to show this across the entire wealth
distribution we have to turn to
numerical solutions and I'm going to
show you that in a second but the other
point that I want to emphasize is that
in this kind of model it's a very simple
model but notice here that you would
always have positive dowries because if
you don't and this is the point that
came up earlier plenitude if the if the
girls parent does not give a positive
dollar to the boy's parent then there's
no way that the boyfriend will ever be
compensated sufficiently because they
need more than X basically and so and
everywhere to live even the last boy to
match he's basically going to get a
dowry okay so this is the byssus the
basic intuition and what you can do as I
said is to solve the model numerically
what we have in the numerical model it's
the same structure as what I just showed
you it's the same basic idea but least
now we just give particular numbers and
we kind of solve it out and you have
hundred wealth classes for the boys side
and hundred wealth classes for the girls
side so the first thing to notice in
this picture is that if you go to the
top of the wealth distribution which is
the hundredth wealth class for the
females and 100 wealth laws for the
males the red line coincides with the
blue line
what is the blue line the blue line is a
45-degree line this is a line at which
the boys wealth and the girl's wealth is
exactly equal so what this is saying is
I'm gonna get to the very top girls with
wealth 100 and boys it worth 100 match
with each other with each other as you
move down notice that the red line
starts to shift away from the blue line
what does that mean that means that
girls are matching with wealthier voice
and this gap keeps widening as you move
down so that is the hypergamy this idea
that as you move further down the wealth
distribution the gap between girls and
boys keeps widening what are the
consequences of this for the sex
selection and this is the intuition that
I give you with that simple example but
now of course we've got the dowries and
then everything is done endogenously and
simultaneously but you still get the
same intuition what you find is on the y
axis over here what you have is a
probability that the child is a girl and
on the x axis you have the wealth class
and so as you move among to higher
higher wealth classes the probability
that the child is a girl keeps decrying
decreasing what happens to your dowry
your dowry is actually increasing so if
I looked at this in the data you would
say look look the diaries are going up
and there are less girls there is this
correlation between the two but what you
can see from us the structure of our
model is that what is driving the sex
selection is not the dowry it's in fact
a social norm that all girls must marry
and that is tilting the balance of power
and fear of the boys versus the girls
there's another force in our model which
also drives sex selection and that has
to do with the seepage which is
basically when the when the girl's
parents gives the dowry to the boy's
parent if you remember the girl only
gets some fraction of that she gets some
fraction of the transfer that the boy's
parents to his son let's call that alpha
and what we assumed was that that was
less than one-half basically as that
that seepage gets larger and larger
having a girl becomes less and less
attractive for the parent and as a
result you start to see more and more
sex selection so that's the second way
in which you can have sex selection in
our model so to sort of summarize all of
this this has been
quite a lot of work but basically what I
want you to take away from this is that
there is a way of understanding why
there will be variation in sex selection
within a narrow caste within a local
area what you should expect to see that
within that caste in a local area
relatively wealthy households will end
up having more sex sex selection than
less wealthy households within costs
okay that's the key prediction now it
turns out that there are there are other
models that could do this without
getting into all of this complication
the reason why we have to go through all
this complications because we're trying
to explain this with the marriage
institution as a starting point suppose
instead you just had boy son preference
suppose for example parents just
preferred boys to girls it's a much
simpler model and you would get the same
prediction that as you move down the
wealth distribution there's going to be
less and less sex selection but our
model I think is preferred for two
reasons the first reason is that with
this alternative model when you just
wear parents just simply for whatever
reason prefer to have sons versus
daughters what ends up happening of
course is that once once the sex
selection has taken place you will still
have a marriage market you will still
have a marriage price but now because
there is a shortage of girls relative to
boys the money will go in the opposite
direction there's going to be a bright
price and you think about for example a
country like China where but by all
accounts there's no problem with a
marriage market the reason by your sex
selection in China is because there is
one at least one son it's a totally
different motivation to ours in China
you have sex selection you have very
high levels of sex selection but you
actually have extremely high bright
prices so when the time comes to decide
whether you won't have a boy or a girl
you do prefer to have a boy but then
once the dust has settled in some sense
and there's a shortage of girls then the
thing - it's over and now basically
you're gonna have these extremely high
prices for girls they can demand very
high premium now in boy in India is
exactly the opposite which is the
strange thing in India you have a
shortage of girls and at the same time
you have extremely high dollies and that
tells you that there must be something
going on in the marriage market itself
which is driving both the dowries as
well as the sex selection the second
distinguishing feature
our model is that if you think about son
preference the usual story is that Paris
want to have at least one son now
suppose you had five kids for example so
when you have the first kid if it's a
girl you're like okay fine you have the
second kid is a girl you're like okay
it's fine but the time you go to the
third kid it's not to worry you don't
know y'all only had two girls maybe I
should do some kind of adjustment but
maybe it won't be too much when you get
to the fourth kid you're gonna really
start to worry and you're gonna start to
do more and more adjustment more parents
without it adjustment but the time you
get to that fifth kid you are really
gonna just see boys and nothing else and
so one implication of son preference is
that as you move to higher and higher
birth orders you're more and more likely
to see boys being born but the other
implication is that for the first birth
but you don't really have this pressure
you really shouldn't be seeing any sex
selection even if you have just want to
kids do you already need to sex select
on that first game you can do all of the
damage or the mischief on the second
game in our model you should be seeing
sex selection everywhere even for the
first buds and it would look at data in
India so this is basically data from the
DHS and then from the ihds and these are
you know these are nationally
representative surveys so you don't have
that many observations so we've done it
should look at all the kids at 0 to 6 in
rural South India and then of course in
ours our census we have lots of data you
can see where we have 80,000 kids but
the main point is that you look at the
sex ratio for the first birds
it's about 106 boys to 100 girls and if
you look at the overall sex ratios it's
about a hundred nine which is basically
the South India average so you can
already see that there's an elevated sex
ratio even for the first points okay
yeah
no no sub estimate that's the
biologically I think you came in later
so 105 at Birth if you're looking at
kids H 0 to 6 so at that point of course
it's going to be catch-up and so the
benchmark that were using 102 point five
so you're elevated even for the first
ones ok so so now let's now that we have
all of this background let me just show
you some results but sort of you know
get to the other sort of you know
keek sort of aspect of this research as
I said one thing was to document that
there is this variation
sex ratios within discuss even in local
area and the second thing was to explain
why you see the sex ratio so I've just
taken you through all of this theory so
now let me just sort of show you the
data okay
so the first thing is that I just showed
you sex ratio is in the study area
I just around the South Indian average
okay they don't really they don't quite
standard
none of the costs in Tamil Nadu that are
traditionally associated with severe sex
selection like the down doors in Salem
district for example none of those class
are actually present in this particular
study area of us and so what I would
like to claim is that even though this
is data from just one district this in
some sense is representative the
marriage institution is organized the
same way in all castes in the country we
have a particular district which looks
very start of standard run-of-the-mill
so why would if you see this in this
particular place you will very likely
see this among all the other cars or
many other cars in the country as well
and that is the point that I want to try
to make okay so let me just get now to
the actual results I'm I'm going to skip
over all of this in the entrance in the
interest of time we have a lot of
control we look at the thing it's a very
robust relationship this is the key
finding this is the relationship between
the probability that a child this is now
in our census data the public that a
child aged 0 to 6 is a girl the relation
between that and the rank of the
household in its caste wealth
distribution so this is based on per
capita wealth or we adjust for the size
of the household and what we do is we
basically find the rank of the caste in
the wealth distribution and the basic
finding is that if you go to the very
bottom of the wealth distribution you
actually have parity or it's like the
above there's a slight excessive growth
which really shouldn't come from our
model but you see this in the data okay
but it's certainly parity you're
definitely you know you're not you're
not badly off at all but by the time it
comes down over here and I'm gonna show
you I'm gonna tell you what the
magnitudes are you basically seen that
there's a very sharp decline in the
probability that the child is a girl now
this is pooling all the cars are about
fifty cars in the study area but it
turns out that twelve cars make up
eighty two percent of the population so
what you can do because of the huge
amount of data that we have it should
look cost
by caste so weird--whoa finding now is
you take the 12 largest cars and plot
the relationship between the probability
that the child is a girl and the
position the houses position in the
wealth distribution cast by caste and
you basically see four out of the twelve
cars it looks exactly right for nine of
them there are three which don't work
there's the one over here I'm not gonna
get into the names but it's basically
the second from right in the second row
and these two over here the rest all
looked pretty good now what I want to
tell you is that when you get down over
here you have less than 2,000 kids and
this is appointment looking at sex
ratios you really need a lot of data to
get stable results and what I'm going to
show you in a second is that when you
switch inside looking at the 0 to 6 year
olds if you look at the 7 to 13 year
olds this is just a previous group they
should have the same patterns and in
fact they indeed they do and now you
look at those problem cars it's perfect
and of course for the larger cost you
keep getting the same patterns now what
is also very striking is if you look at
the two largest cars you have the
Vanya's who are a land owning cost
they're an upper-class and you have the
ugly drivers who are the lowest of the
low cost the traditional name which is
that you should not be used at all
anymore its pariah
so the indent is the English word pariah
comes from this cos name these are two
cars which are the polar opposite ends
of the social spectrum but if you look
in our data what you find is exactly the
same patterns for both of these costs
yes yeah so it's no but it's we can't
really explain this level of details so
it is coming up but we cannot
statistically we probably will be to
reject that in fact they're kind of the
same so there this is data so we can't
we can't exactly get the pattern you
know that the theory would predict of
course it's going to turn up a bit over
here sometimes is going to go bunch up
and down a bit over here and that's just
that's just statistics that that's kind
of where we are with that okay so this
is sort of as I said the key result and
and to give you a sense of the magnitude
of these effects what you can look at is
what how much of the variation in sex
ratios in this entire study area can be
explained
within cos and between Gaza and the you
just I would be there are certain costs
which are really bad and they're the
ones who are doing all the sex selection
but what you find in a study area if you
take this the 30 largest cars is that
seventy percent of the variation is
within cost and you would take the
twelve largest cars is that it's as much
as eighty seven percent so most of the
variation is in fact happening within
cost and the point that I want to
emphasize is if you did not have our
data they would there would be no way
for you to ever even see this this is
the first time that anyone's ever been
able to look at this level of detail
within these cars and what you find is
something extremely striking now if
there's another way to look at the
magnitude of the variation which is it
should look at the sex ratios across the
wealth distribution if you divide up the
wealth distribution to eight wealth
plusses the lowest wealth class as I
said you actually have parity a little
bit you know even better than party
there's a slight excess of girls there's
ninety seven boys to whatever one
hundred three hundred girls whatever
right but at the worst place it is one
hundred and seventeen and think back to
the first slide that I showed you with
Delhi and Haryana and Punjab they were
right over there it was like 118 120
Delhi 115 so basically the variation in
sex ratios within these castes in one
district which has a relatively
inconspicuous sex ratio overall of 108
is as much as a variation across states
in the country and so this is something
that we really need to think about as we
move forward because most of the
attention has been on particular
problematic states or casts like the
charts or the gounder's for example in
Salem where people already know that
these are the these are the problem
places but if our results are are more
general then what this tells us is in
fact this problem is way more pervasive
then people have realized this could be
through all the four thousand costs if
it looked within them you might find
these patterns and you would never see
this it was just a district level data
and so we really need to now ask
ourselves what could you do to deal with
the problem now what's nice about our
analysis I took you through all this
hard work of working through the model
once the model is set up we've already
done the numerical we solve the model
numerically we can estimate the
parameters of this model and we can do
counterfactual experiments and we can
ask ourselves suppose there was a policy
change what would happen to the sexy
light sex selection and what our model
would do is allow the dowries to shift
and will allow the wealth distributions
to shift everything would happen
endogenously because our model is now
all set up to match the data so guess
what if you put in the household well
directly which is the absolute part you
get a positive and significant effect
good it's goes in the opposite anything
putting those things in makes it
stronger yeah no I'm doing everything
wrong because our data's yeah yeah so I
don't see anything about the open by the
way yeah no so our bottle is not dynamic
so what we're trying to do is some way
this is a very good question so we're
not trying to explain the change from
pre-1982 post-1980 our bottle basically
kicks in in the post 1980 period when
the mass market is already in place
we're not trying to explain the change
at all we're looking at the world which
currently exists where the sex selection
where the mass market has already
emerged our analysis is cross-sectional
it's non dynamic that was just
motivational what I was telling you
earlier our analysis is not trying to
explain I can't because I don't have
data over time we have a one time census
so I can't do what you would that would
be very nice by data over time from
let's say 1975 to to now I could
actually look over time and see these
changes but I can't do that
absolutely so let me Karen get to that
later I will talk about that actually
the seepage the alpha and at the very
end I'll talk about that it's not part
of my analysis it's gonna be something
that I'm going to talk about as sort of
future research because we can't in our
model
there's a fixed alpha at a particular
point in time now if I made this seepage
rate you had a question
no okay so let me just say let me just
conclude by doing one final thing which
is to say but now that we have this
model set up can we actually do some
kind of counterfactual Policy
experiments and one thing to do here is
you actually think about current
policies that are in place they are I
mean everyone knows that this is a
problem and so there are many state
governments as well as a the central
government where I that have schemes in
place to try to deal explicitly with sex
selection and one very popular scheme is
a conditional cash transfer program but
basically what they do is they they
parents of girls they receive a transfer
at different points in the girl's life
so when the girls birth is registered
and they do the regular you know the
required immunizations they get some
transfer when the girl completes primary
school they get some transfer when she
completes highest higher secondary
school they get some transfer and in
addition there is a discharge cover
which matures when she turns 18 or 20 at
which point the money goes into a bank
account in her name now of course it's
not clear because the bank accountant is
her name
who actually gets it is it her parents
is it her is that the in-laws we don't
know that but in our politics permits
we're gonna allow for the possibility
that somehow the money could go directly
to her and we're going to see what
happens in our model to sex selection as
a result of that the other feature of
these schemes which is actually
important is that many of the schemes
actually restrict the transfers to
families below a particular wealth level
and I think these are well-intentioned
schemes the general you think wittzcouch
conditional care transfers you want to
give it to poor households but in this
particular case given what I've just
shown you you're actually giving it to
the houses which are not at most risk so
what's going to happen as a result of
that so this is basically what you find
okay so the blue line is
the bear is the benchmark this is what
is predicted by our model okay the solid
red line is this conditional cash
transfer which is given only to the poor
families so in our model in this sort of
simple model that we have over here
there are eight wealth classes and what
we specify is that it's only the bottom
two wealth classes that get the transfer
sorry
this is the bottom oh sorry let me
explain to you okay so this is now I've
gone back to the sex ratio now so this
is not this is more money this is less
money yeah and also just to clarify just
that you don't get confused now I've
gone back because this is now policy
experiment about the government of India
reports which is a number of boys per
hundred girls
so this is the blue line is the
benchmark when you put in this
conditional cash transfer program the
number of boys to girls before the
bottom two Bell classes does drop quite
a lot but that's what you would expect
but guess what happens to the higher
classes they actually get worse and why
is that the case and that's I think the
power of our model because remember here
in our model the doughies are adjusting
endogenously so when you suddenly have
more girls over here at the bottom
they're going to put an upward pressure
on the dowry and that's going to affect
the entire wealth distribution and a
result of that all the girls at the top
are going to get affected of girls pairs
are going to realize that things are not
getting more and more affected by this
higher dowry and as a result there's
going to be more sex selection so if you
look at the overall effect in fact you
just did the math you'd find that the
net effect of this is actually negative
so a very well-intentioned program is
actually going to end up giving
worsening the sex selection on average
now if you had the other model where the
sex selection was just you know given as
a preference you would not have this
additional effect you would have an
improvement over here and then this and
on the top nothing would change by what
but you can see you know that when you
when you model it in this way you can
see that there is a sort of what they
call a general equilibrium effect
through the marriage price which affects
the entire wealth distribution now what
you could do instead is to just give it
to all
not just the poor girls you don't get
much of an effect at all I mean is this
positive but it's not being very much at
all the much better the more effective
of strategy is to give the same amount
of money directly to the girls it's her
parents who are making the decision
obviously about sex selection but they
are altruistic and they honor that want
you to the mind directed to the girl
there's no seepage and as a result they
are way better off now and as a result
you have much much less sex selection so
one sort of you know take away from this
is that you have to be very careful with
these kinds of programs very
well-intentioned programs like this can
actually worsen the problem the other
thing you won't you might want to take
away from this is that if you could
somehow target the girls directly give
the money directly to married women you
would do much better we'd be much better
off then give them my to their parents
when they were children and then the
last question which gets back to the
point you're making about you know the
changes in the seepage over time is is
there anything that we can do that would
directly sort of you know address the
the root cause of the problem the root
cause of the problem is two things the
social norm that all girls must marry
and the seepage but the girl essentially
is getting just a fraction of the
transfer that the husband receives and
why is that is because she has less
bargaining power within the household
now one way to deal with both of these
problems would be to actually increase
female labor force participation now
this is something which I don't know
whether you're familiar with this but
female labor force participation in
India is abysmal alone it's about 40%
and if anything is been getting worse
over time in our study area more
educated women are less likely to work
female education levels are actually
right now in our study area very high if
you look at higher secondary school
enrolment it's the same for girls as it
is for boys but it doesn't make a
difference because at the end of the day
they don't enter enter the labor force
if they don't enter the labor force they
are not independent if they did enter
the labor force then this social norm
would no longer be relevant because a
girl could be single but she would be
economically independent and she would
be fine if she did marry she'd have more
bargaining power because she was working
so for all of these reasons beyond just
the standard growth you know I mean of
course there are many reasons why you
want women to work but there are now
you can see that this is going to have
an additional effect through these
channels on something as basic as sex
selection so I want to conclude over
here with one final slide which is just
showing you what we could have if the
world was better yep no but that would
be that's useful to know well you may
ultrasound so when Isis applies right
but you know but if you do not have a
demand but if you did not have a demand
I mean I understand what you're saying
so obviously if you I mean making sex
erection cheaper is going to worsen a
problem that exists in the first place
but that's not you know I'm not ignoring
that no I'm not ignoring that at all so
and as I said I I said I said what we
were trying to do here was to Stu strip
down to focus on the essential features
the womb and the hands would make the
problem less severe because she would
actually bring something to the table
which we don't have in our model
so now model you as you correctly said
we've stripped him down so that we made
it made her essentially just a you know
parasite she's just consuming and doing
not contributing in any way if she
actually contributed then of course the
situation would be different and and
then of course you could adjust the
dowry will adjust etc but the point that
I want to make is that at some level the
'martha she's going to be right now is
still not sufficient and the reason why
it's not sufficient is because women are
not working so they can work in the
house and they can bring up the children
but where until they actually end up
going into the labor force and earning
independently the kind of story that I'm
painting for you at some level is going
to carry through that's the point that I
want to make
yes not well I'm not sure because if we
look even at urban India I don't think
that labor force participation rates are
going up this is the puzzle about India
I mean there many puzzles about our
development this is certainly you know
one of them we are just not able to
somehow increase female labor force
participation rates if anything they are
going down overtime with development
it's just you know I mean it's something
worth considering and thinking about it
could be you know this is where at some
point we want to stop thinking just
about the economics and think about you
know social norms and other things as
well I would certainly think that this
is a place to do that don't get me wrong
I I mean I was I took a very economic
position here because I wanted to focus
on one particular aspect of sex
selection which has to do with the
marriage market and because it's a
market I thought it's fair to take a
very economic position to really
understand the functioning of that
market but there are a lot of norms
floating around over here we have the
norm that all girls must marry we have
this low female labor force
participation we have all sorts of
things floating around over here which
are not economic and I don't want to at
all push this idea that you know it's
all about the economics and not about
other things okay not at all that's not
my position they do but that's precisely
why they have the girl just thing is
exactly right that's precisely the
motivation for why you have less
acceleration this is precisely you have
to exactly the right mechanism that's
exactly right yeah
mostly because as I see the market of
managing a wheel also market this is a
market between rows per inch of oil
spills so you know we giving it giving
the money directly to them so to give
them control but the story of debris is
not just transferring money to those but
also performing your parental obligation
of it and with the problem of dowry we
may think of girls or torn you over the
money second so this was an item to
spell something the story so unsightly
the question of is that how what are
your thoughts about instead of
participation so to expanding the logic
of household income rather than personal
income which kids
with response your second question I
think that I think that one of the key
drivers in our model is in fact this
idea that she doesn't end up actually
consuming at the same level as her
husband that there is this sort of you
know inequality and if you could somehow
change that then you would certainly do
better the question of course is how
would you I mean this is where you know
I mean we can sit down and write down
models and talk about different policies
etc but how you actually implement these
things is another matter so how would
you actually within the household really
change the allocation of resources I
mean this is something which is really
really incredibly challenging right I
mean it's not just a matter of me how
would you how would you ever stipulate
that you know within a marital household
the woman has some right over her
husband's property for example it's just
I just don't see how you could do it
right I mean certainly there's no role
for for perhaps there's a legal
framework that could be used in some way
to do this but you know on the ground in
practice you know it's not clear how you
could actually implement such a such a
scheme right I mean these are all you
know these are also and you know getting
back into your first question about you
know how could you you know if in fact
the girl's parent could actually give
the mine directly to her dad would
actually in our model solve the product
problem completely because a girl's
brain would just say okay I've got why
I'll keep wild / - the girl gets why / -
perfect but all set the problem is then
how would you actually ever implement
such a thing because even if you gave
the money directly to the girl she could
do that let us say you changed as
somebody change the setup so the money
goes directly into a bank account with
the girl's name how can you stop - her
husband I mean this is what you know
when I was working many years ago in
South India all these tea plantations
and you know women get all this jewelry
at the time of marriage right but what
do you think
to that jewelry the basically the
husband drinks and he pawns the jewelry
to you know do whatever else he wants to
do with the money right so even even
nothing ultimately is out of out of the
control at some level within a household
of other family members and that's the
nature of a family right how can you how
can you separate you know how can you
assign property rights within a family
it's just not I don't see how you can do
it actually you can do it legally
uniformly but then actually what happens
in reality in practice is a completely
different matter I would think so I
would hope so I mean I would to me this
seems like the critical thing I mean I
and this is something I never thought
about earlier at all I mean again
mushrik might know more about from the
bangladeshi case and I think there'd
been many positive aspects right I'm you
put some work on this right with Rachel
Heaton you know you have this sort of
you know this is female employment and
then there are very positive outcomes in
those particular villages in terms of
education of the kids and stuff right
and marriage changes too so this is sort
of I think you know I mean here's an
example I think of a success story where
you know you have extremely high labor
force participation rates and we are
very positive or something about in guys
it's very interesting you know I mean
there are many puzzles that I as I keep
working on this country
yeah yeah but is it something which is
really needs to be you know thought
about it and I said I think that economy
should be there and on you know looking
at this but it's not going to be a story
simply about markets and returns to
education this is something you know
about clearly about norms and
aspirations and something much much more
fundamental you know which has to be
taken on board yeah because if you go if
you're working then all of a sudden
because right now I think that's
probably part of the problem right it's
the shame of the husband of the parents
the girl's gonna stay at home with them
but do you know what if she works she's
out she's doing her own thing you know
it's okay right five thousand five I'm
rich it was fifty five five thousand
households yes it's very detailed it
includes a lot of anthropometric
measures which were using in other
research so they are actually looking
for example there's another puzzle in
India III which you all might be aware
of which is that Indians have extremely
low nutritional status where among the
the least way were our BMI is extremely
extremely extremely low despite you know
many decades of economic development and
so one things you wanted to do is should
look at height for age BMI aviod also we
collected a lot of Antrim Prometric
measures but we also want to link that
for example to to sort of you know
diseases like diabetes and
cardiovascular disease which is again is
extremely high prevalence in the South
Asian population so we so that was part
of the survey so we collected lots of
information about the parental inputs
into the children the amount of time
that that parents spent with their
children on different activities the the
expenditures are you know schooling and
you know all sorts of stuff this whole
so those those things would take
typically about three hours or so to to
complete so it was a very detailed
survey
so we first hit the sensor so the reason
one of the reason why we did the census
is you might think this is gonna have a
crazy thing to do but how do you
actually pick five thousand random
households which are representative
unfortunately the only way to do it
right is to do a census first that's
pretty costly so one of the reasons why
we have this this data is because we did
the census first and so now we have that
date and then from the census data we
could draw houses that were represented
so we have a sort of representative
sample based on the cars composition of
the area etc so now we can actually when
we look at the data that these five
thousand households it's not just some
you know stop is it they are really
representative of this of this
population no no we don't pay fees no no
we don't yeah and that was fine I mean
and you know I mean most people tell you
as well I mean one of the advantages of
so I did once upon a time I did a survey
of the diamond industry in Bombay and
you can imagine how difficult that was
so I spent two years literally literally
building up connections within the
industry and then I actually use my
connections to essentially break into
the things otherwise even given talk to
you for a second
[Music]
but that's like the China story right so
ex-ante I mean so so so one good thing
about this is that at the time you know
before enough time of whatever
conception you got to make a decision
and and in the very simple model that I
had for you they were sort of always a
benefit to switching from a girl to a
boy but what I didn't maybe you know
give enough detail to was there what we
assumed as that there's a debt that the
cost of sex selection is not the same
for everyone so there are some people
who will do it others would not and
that's where I think also the cultural
norms and differences across cars and
across different regions of the country
really comes in it might be a lot easier
for you to do this if you happen to
belong to a particular caste where this
is a common practice for example but
what we assume here of course we're in
all of that because we're looking within
cost but but the assumption is that
there are some that there is a
distribution of sex selection costs and
that's the reason why there will be some
families which will do it and others
were not
and so in at the end sort of in
equilibrium there's going to be boys and
there will be girls and so when the time
comes to marry then of course you will
you know the parents of girls and the
parents of boys will match just as we
show in the model
so to my mind I don't think there's
anything inconsistent about that right
you make a decision at a particular
point of time that is right for you
given the cost of sex selection
which is specific to you and then you
know further down the road given the sex
of your child you you know operate in a
marriage market accordingly but well
this is the thing I mean you can do yes
so we did lots of you know like before
we did some but so these are very long
service I've been talking about these
three hours right so we literally spent
I think you know to give you a sense of
how long this took I began this project
in 2007 okay so we don't do things
slowly and we are very careful even
economies are careful believe it or not
and it took us a long time to actually
get the funding from the NIH to actually
do this to get permission from the
Indian government to actually do this
and then we spent years so for a very
long period of time I should spend three
to four months in this particular place
and this was the only thing that I was
working on for a very very long period
of time and when we actually did these
surveys it was literally you know going
through this thing month after month
after month talking to people getting
their feedback writing out the
questionnaire sending people back into
the field going back and forth going
back and forth until we actually were
able to come up with an instrument that
actually was working so I like to think
that we are and and and if you look at
the list of you know the people I was
I'm working with there are sociologists
on this there are you know medical
doctors on this but he's our people in
the Lord the Christian Medical College
who have been working in this area for a
very very long period of time so they
know this place very very well they know
the population so we did not just pick a
random population we are working with
Indian collaborators who know this place
very well and some of these people have
become I should also mention that one of
my co-authors on this project she was
when I started this project she was at
the what was called the tuberculosis
research center because this project
began as a project on TB alone and then
it sort of grew in many different ways
then she moved from there to become the
director-general of the Indian Council
of medical research and a few weeks ago
she was appointed as the deputy
director-general of the WH o so I have a
very famous person sitting on this table
but we started off at least with her
when I started off she was in this very
you know ramshackle the office in the
middle of nowhere and then in the last
ten years you know she's kind of gone
very far so
no no no no no no no I wish that was
true we didn't collect paper all the
time no no we that's true that's a good
point
the question of course is how much
migration is there in India so well not
in this particular paper but I have
another paper quite recently looking at
rural to urban migration in India and
and what we find in that paper what we
document in that paper is that in fact
permanent migration in India is
extremely low this is another puzzle of
the Indian economy is that it's
exceptionally though you have temporary
migration but temporary migration in
some sense as mushrik will tell you is
is a very different story because in
some sense you're still connected so the
type of migration that you're worried
about where the boy essentially moves
away and it's a different world and
there's no seepage etc is not going to
really be very important at peace at
this point in time as far as isn't that
research you know tells us so that would
be my my response but that's a very good
question by the way so it's certainly
relevant
but you know I think you're right the
venue when the cost of sex collection
goes down you're going to have more sex
selections true in levels but that was
not going to explain why within a caste
you find this particular pattern it is
true that what you're finding here this
range from zero 217 maybe would not be
that much but the point I'm trying to
make you would look on average in this
population you don't have that much sex
selection is only 108 the key point is
that within that 108 is seeing a lot of
variation under the surface and you
would not even know that if you just a
district level data so that is based on
we what we did as we broke up the cause
into eight wealth classes equal sized
wealth classes and the lowest wealth
class has a sex ratio of 97 170
it's not the highest actually turns are
not data as you saw there was a little
dips was in fact the next-to-last wealth
class which turns out in the data to
have the lowest one and that's 170 well
it's very large we have eighty thousand
kids right that's the thing that's why
we can only do it with this data I mean
otherwise you could not do it because
with sex selection in some sense you're
almost close to you know just noise
right 108 you know when you cut below
105 you're really in the world where
we're sort of you know think of this as
statistical error yeah
yeah sure so if if if I spoke to if I
use the word income in the talk it was
an error because you should oh no I just
only be the dowry which is it was a
dowry where I talked about the fraction
of it is used three to four times the
annual income but otherwise in terms of
the model of the annual income but in
terms of the model it's always going to
be involved now not that you're asking
me this I can tell you something which I
didn't mention in the talk just in the
interest of time which is that when we
do the census we don't actually collect
data on the wealth of these households
what we collect is the income in the
last year so we asked them how much did
you earn from your land through you know
their land that you own leased or rented
plus all of the labor income and we
combine that into an annual income now
no it's only the floor it's tough it's
the it's the income flow which is in
some sense is is is is a fraction of the
total wealth stock that you have so
there's a wealth stock and then there's
an income flow that comes out of that
van stock so in principle there's
nothing wrong with using income as a
proxy for wealth but a problem is when
you use income however you're going to
get transitory you're gonna get noise
it's very noisy so what we do and that
was something which came out very
coincidentally is that I was actually
working on a different project on the
assimilation of South Asian immigrants
from the Punjab in the UK and I was in
the British Library working on that and
I discovered that in this that the
British colonial government had done a
very detailed survey of this particular
area in 1871 now in 1871 they collected
the revenue per cultivated acre from
each of these villages not all of them
but most of them all of the ones where
they had what was called the right value
system so the German dairy villages of
course we don't have been the data but
for all there are re villages we
actually had information about the the
land revenue per acre that was collected
by the colonial government well it turns
out is that that interacted with cast
dummies is a very strong predictor of
your income today it's amazing
from 1871 it predicts your income today
extremely well
and so in what I've shown you actually
is not the actual income it's the
predicted income based on the 1871 data
adjusted of course for the size of the
family so it's per capita well so in
that sense it is really a good it is
really a wealth measure because you're
really using this historical thing to
predict it and that purges all the the
noise so it's that's that's the point so
if you use that on its own and you could
and this is all in the in the paper you
don't get very strong effects because of
this measurement error but once you
predict it then the effects become much
stronger but what you have to remember
here is that you distinguish between
absolute wealth and relative wealth so
you might think that a poorer household
for example might have a particular
preference for boys versus girls because
it returns two boys are different
returns two girls depending on the
wealth that you have but as I was
telling mushrik we control for the
household wealth in absolute the reason
is because we had multiple costs so you
can separately identify the relative
wealth effect and the absolute wealth
ability and most of this kind of stories
that you will be talking about would not
be about relative wealth it will not be
about your position within the caste
distribution it would just be simply
about how much money do I have to have
fifty rupees or do I have a hundred
rupees
that's what matters so we can separate
out these two effects and that's the
part that I kind of skipped over well
you know what you wanted to look at the
controls etc
[Applause]
[Music]